A DNA sequence is just a string of DNA letters in consecutive order. So for
example, over here on the left. Even though
this is double stranded DNA molecule, the DNA
sequence is only read from one strand at a time. We would read either G, A, C,
G, T, C, A, C, T, C, or C, T, G, C, A, G, T,
G, A, G. The important thing to note is that, because of the base pairing rules
of DNA, if you know the sequence of one strand, Then we should already know the
sequence of the complementary strand. So if you just have the sequence on the
left, you would know that it pairs with C, T, G, C.
A G T G A G. And
this is really useful for us in genetics. From now on,
instead of writing out double-stranded
DNA sequences, we'll write out single-stranded
sequences to keep things simple. When you see a string of
DNA letters like this We'll refer to this as a DNA sequence.